un usuario de youtube me mandó un
problema que está muy interesante así
que es el problema que voy a resolver en
este vídeo este problema dice lo
siguiente dice sabemos que f deje de x
es igual a dos veces la raíz cuadrada de
x cuadrada más uno menos uno entre entre
la raíz cuadrada de x cuadrada más 1 más
1 y también sabemos que fx es igual a 2
x menos uno
/ / x más 1 ok entonces la pregunta es
sabiendo que fg de x es esta expresión
que se ve complicadísima y que fx es
igual a 2 x menos 1 entre x + 1 cuál es
el valor cuál es el valor de x
queremos determinar cuánto vale x
muy bien pues este problema resulta que
podemos hacerlo a simple vista cómo le
hacemos pues lo primero que voy a hacer
es calcular
efe gx sin saber quiénes gdx simplemente
usando la definición de f déjame hacerlo
aquí abajo es decir voy a ver quién es
efe deje de x usando esta definición la
de f entonces qué tenemos que hacer
donde aparezca x debemos de poner la
expresión g x eso es lo que se hace
cuando evaluamos una función verdad
entonces nos quedaría 2 por gd x 2 por
gdx menos uno dividido dividido entre
gdx gdx más 1 muy bien pero además
sabemos que fg de x es igual a esta
expresión que está aquí arriba es decir
esto es igual a 2 x raíz
de x cuadrada 11 / raíz de x 1
+ 1 y a partir de aquí pues únicamente
debemos identificar el patrón observa
aquí tenemos dos veces esta función g
menos 1 y aquí estamos dividiendo entre
g de x más 1 y aquí es la misma idea con
raíz de x cuadrada más 1 esta expresión
aparece aquí y aparece acá y de esta
forma podemos obtener kg de x es igual a
la raíz cuadrada la raíz cuadrada de x
cuadrada más 1 muy bien entonces esta es
una forma de hacerlo así a simple vista
encontramos cuál es la función que sirve
pero de hecho el ejemplo que me mandaron
hasta viene con opciones así que otra
forma de resolver este problema teniendo
estas opciones es sustituyendo las en fx
para ver cuál de las opciones nos da
efe gx según propone el problema vamos a
hacer eso claro o sea antes lo hice de
esta forma para que vieras que se puede
hacer incluso sin tener las opciones
pero vamos a hacerlo con las opciones
para ver
podríamos hacerlo de una forma un poco
más fácil entonces las opciones las
opciones que nos da el problema es que x
puede ser a puede ser raíz de x o puede
ser
a raíz de x cuadrada más 1
1 o puede ser la función x o la función
sin aquí debería ponerle de la función x
cuadrada
la función x cuadrada más 1 x cuadrada
más 1 ahora ya sabemos que la opción
correcta es la opción b pero vamos a ver
qué sucede cuando sustituimos las otras
opciones si ponemos raíz de x sijé x
fuera igual a raíz de x entonces efe gx
sería dos veces raíz de x dos veces raíz
de x menos 1 / dividido entre raíz de x
+ 1
entonces obtendríamos pues esta
expresión y esta expresión no es la
misma que la que queremos esta no es
efe deje de x como nos lo pide el
problema entonces esta opción no es la
opción b si sabemos que es ahorita me
las alto si ponemos aquí que x es igual
a x entonces cuando componemos efe con g
obtendríamos simplemente esta expresión
verdad obtendríamos 2x menos 1 dividido
entre x + 1 y esto no es la expresión
que queremos de modo similar si le
ponemos x al cuadrado obtendríamos
2x cuadrada menos uno dividido entre x
cuadrada más uno que una vez más no es
lo que queremos y finalmente si ponemos
x cuadrada más uno obtendríamos 2x
cuadrada más uno menos 1 / / / x
cuadrada más uno más uno
entonces bueno aquí podríamos
simplificar un poco más pero incluso
simplificando no queda esta expresión
que queremos de esta forma el único
chance es que la opción sea b y en
efecto si ponemos eje x igual a raíz de
x al cuadrado más 1 justo obtenemos que
f deje de x es la expresión que queremos
vale entonces lo que hicimos primero es
resolverlo a simple vista y ahorita lo
resolvemos lo resolvimos checando cada
una de las opciones y la opción b es la
correcta bueno espero que este vídeo te
haya sido de ayuda y sobre todo espero
que le haya ayudado a este usuario que
me mandó la pregunta nos vemos hasta la
próxima